here's what happened in the Croatia
Brazil World Cup quarterfinal
[Applause]
the first half was a battle in the
Midfield but remained goalless after the
first 45 with Croatia giving Brazil
plenty to think about Brazil started the
second half strong but still couldn't
unlock the Croatian defense so full time
ended with a 0-0 draw so it went to
extra time Croatia's fifth in the last
two World Cups
Neymar finally broke the deadlock in the
105th minute with a wonder goal after
going one-on-one with the keeper but
Croatia refused to give up
barely 10 minutes later they sprung on
the counter-attack and Bruno Pekovic
from across fired and deflected shot
into the back of Allison's net the two
sides were level once again at the end
of extra time so penalties would decide
the winner Nikola Vlasic fired Croatia's
first shot right down the middle and
Croatia's keeper Dominic livakovich
firmly denied Rodrigo's first penalty
for Brazil Meyer slotted another penalty
down the center of Allison's net giving
Croatia an early Advantage then casemiro
gave Brazil a Lifeline by scoring a
commanding penalty Croatia's 37 year old
Captain Luca Modric scored his next
Brazil forward Pedro also scored mislav
Orchid slotted his penalty and in the
deciding shot marquinos hit the post
[Applause]
Croatia took the win 4-2 on penalties
Brazil had 11 shots on target to just
one for Croatia but still Croatia came
out on top and for the third time in
their history they're heading to the
World Cup semi-final okay
[Applause]